und als will ich euch auch sagen es gibt
nicht die werte union und die union der
mitte es gibt nur eine wertung union und
das ist die cdu deutschland und es gibt
noch einen jungen damit ist unser 584
tag werden
ja der leipziger parteitag beschädigung
war alles in allem natürlich eine
befriedung der cdu so was kann man schon
sagen die reihen sind geschlossen die
vorsitzende hat mit ihrem gestrigen
manöver es geschafft ihre partei wieder
hinter sich zu kriegen wenn ihr der
meinung seid dass dieser weg den ich
gemeinsam mit euch gehen möchte nicht
der weg ist den ihr für den richtigen
halt dann lasst es uns heute aussprechen
und lasst es uns heute auch beenden hier
und jetzt und heute und es wurde
tatsächlich wie man sich vorgenommen
hatte viel inhaltlich gearbeitet sogar
ganz überwiegend ist wurden beschlüsse
gefasst zur rentenpolitik
es wurde der lange währende streit über
eine grundrente jetzt auch mit dem segen
der cdu-delegierten versehen man hat
sich geeinigt was keine kleinigkeit war
es gab eine lange debatte über die
landwirtschaftspolitik die sehr wichtig
ist für die cdu wählerschaft und die cdu
klientel und die auch in schwierigen
zeiten ist wie man unter anderem in
bayern oder in baden württemberg sieht
also es wurde eine menge inhaltlich
gearbeitet dann dann lasst uns hier und
jetzt und heute die ärmel hochkrempeln
und anfangen vielen dank
was allerdings nicht herausgekommen ist
ist ein großes thema in großer
inhaltlicher beschluss mit dem sich die
cdu jetzt identifizieren könnte mit
denen sie vor ihre mitglieder an ihre
wähler tritt und sagt das ist ein thema
das haben nur wir das haben die anderen
nicht man hat nachgearbeitet
in der klimapolitik in der steuerpolitik
alles themen über die man reden muss
auch zur digitalisierung auch hier wurde
eine lange debatte geführt auch hier
wurde ein schwelender streit über die
beteiligung des chinesischen anbieters
huawei beigelegt also alles große
leistung aber doch letztendlich themen
die
der parteien bedienen und das was
eigentlich mal das ansinnen auch der
vorsitzenden kramp karrenbauer war
wieder mehr identifikations themen in
den vordergrund zu stellen zb eine
dienstpflicht ein soziales pflichtjahr
das war hier kein beschluss das soll
erst in den wochen nach dem parteitag in
einem werkstattgespräch behandelt werden
also die mitglieder und delegierten
können nach hause fahren von leipzig in
der gewissheit die reihen sind zumindest
wieder geschlossen
für den moment aber letztendlich hechelt
man doch ein bisschen den großthemen
alle anderen parteien hinterher und
setzt kein eigenes letztlich ist
wahrscheinlich das große thema der cdu
nach wie vor doch wir müssen
regierungsfähig sein
wir müssen in der lage sein das land zu
führen
denn wir sind ja keine themen partei
sondern wir sind ein wollen eine
volkspartei sein das ist zumindest hier
wieder deutlich geworden und das ist
vermutlich dann auch der erfolg dieses
parteitages aus sicht der cdu führung